what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be talking about something that i
believe the mannose fear gets wrong they
get incorrect
and they yeah wrong wrong wrong
um before i start do not forget to
subscribe i'm not even going to ask you
to like or comment
but you can if you want to um
just subscribe i'm trying to hit 20 000
subscribers if you guys want to support
me and support my channel
hit that subscribe button okay i'm going
to jump right into it
i want to talk about gold diggers women
or people in the nanosphere seem to have
this like
notion of women that it's only about how
much money you make
and let me tell you i do not believe
that's true
as a girl something that i look for not
just in dating or whatever
is work ethic i like being around people
that work hard so it's not necessarily
about the money if a dude's doing a
coaching job
working hard at it and really like
putting in the hours
wants to be the best that he can be
that's totally fine
um but
women and it's the same thing with like
skills
like you have to work hard to get skills
like genuinely
i believe that it is a god-given like
duty
from god to do the best with what you
have and to work hard
so i don't know i don't know if that
clears anything up but for me personally
like
it's really not about
it's really not about money and it's
never been about money and i know a lot
of like
normal average like girls that it's not
about money for
i mean obviously you're gonna have your
typical like gold diggers the girls that
have been hot since they were young and
never really had to develop real skills
other than being hot like that's
obviously
gonna happen but what i'm saying is you
can bring
and you can attract a lot of different
women by developing skills and just
working hard at what you're doing
it's not necessarily about a dollar
amount
but let me know in the comments if you
guys agree or disagree
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel just my two cents i'm gonna talk
to you guys
next time